Let's pray together over day 35, Holiness and the Mind.
Father, we thank you for the assurance that you have given us a
brain to think. We thank you for it.
We give praise to you for the assurance that you
control and lead us and guide us in our mind,
and we pray for the transformation of our
minds into the image and the nature of Jesus Christ.
Lord, we would ask that you would draw near to our processes
of thought, that you would be with us in those moments that we might
not be deceived or guided
wrongly by our brain, but instead we would capture the
wandering thoughts that we have and that we would recognize the attacks of the
enemy in our mind, and that we would make
those
thoughts give up their wandering around and surrender and
give up and obey Jesus.
We pray, Lord, that you would give direction and leadership to
our thinking so that our minds are no
longer conformed to the pattern of the world but
instead are transformed to be brand new minds.
And would you help us to have the courage to speak to
ourselves in psalms and hymns and spiritual
songs and sing and make melody in our heart to the Lord?
We pray, Lord, for the strength to be able to yield to the
influence of the Holy Spirit. So at this moment, right now,
we surrender every single part of our brain, our old
habits of thought, every synapse, every
brain cell to the lordship of Jesus
Christ and ask that the Holy Spirit would sovereignly
influence every single portion of our brain's thinking.
Transform us, Lord, and burn new
superhighways that are holy in our mind.
We pray in Jesus' name.
Let's continue praying and seeking the Lord together in your own words.